Is there a way to find your true passion
or is that just a cliche,
was definitely a cliche and it and it,
you know,
it,
it's the sort of thing that actually
annoys me quite a lot about new age
thinkers and I would more or less put
Joseph Campbell in that category.
Um,
I think you can find what compels you
and what might enable you to live in a
high quality manner despite the
suffering that's associated with life.
I think you can discover that and I
think part of the way you discover that
is by watching yourself and learning
when it is that you're meaningfully
engaged.
You have to notice that it's something
that happens to you in some sense rather
than something that you do.
You have to notice when you're
meaningfully engaged and then you have
to work to expand the amount of time
that you spend in that state.
But I would also say that there are
moral requirements that go along with
that too because you might say,
well,
what if you happen to be the sort of
person,
for example,
who finds torturing small animals
meaningfully engaging?
I'm like,
it seems like that's a,
that's the sort of meaningful engagement
that you probably don't want to expand.
So I would say that if you're going to
set up your life so that you maximize
your meaningful engagement,
you have to.
There's a number of other things that
you have to do at the same time.
And one of those is that you have to get
very clear about who you are and what
you're doing.
And so although this would be grounds
for a much longer discussion,
I think that one of the things that you
have to do if you're going to attempt to
maximize,
make meaningful engagement,
is that you also have to do such things
as
um,
endeavor to stop deceiving yourself and
other people in every way you possibly
can.
And part of the reason for that is that
if you engage in deception of any sort,
you pathologize the structure first,
the structure of your being.
But you could say you pathologize the
structure of your nervous system and
then you can't trust it's reports.
So if you're,
if you're going to rely on your nervous
system's reports of meaningful
engagement to guide your future
activities,
you better do everything you can to make
sure that you're not filling that
nervous system with the kind of garbage
that's going to make it malfunctioned
and giving again,
give you a false reports.
So I think that moving towards
meaningful engagement has to be
associated with making truth,
your highest value because otherwise you
can't trust yourself as your own guide
in the Catholics have struggled with
this for a long time from a theological
perspective because the Catholic
position,
roughly speaking,
is that human beings are so steeped in
sin that they can't trust their own
instincts in relationship to good and
evil and have to use the church and the
priesthood as an intermediary.
And you know,
you can obviously have an argument about
that and of course Protestants have
historically done that,
but you've got to give the Catholics
there do.
It's like people aren't pure by nature
and only traveled in their vision by
it'll sociological impediments there.
Also corrupt beyond belief individually
and have to use society as a source of
value.
So if you're going to personalize your
life in some sense,
you better act in a manner that makes
you a reliable guide.